we're starting off the work week with
news about
the work week it might be getting
shorter
bloomberg business reports that
companies around the world are trying to
figure out the four
day work week one berlin tech company
tried it during lockdown
paying employees exactly the same amount
for four days
instead of five and they found that by
the numbers
sales employee engagement and client
satisfaction
all increased in fact two-thirds of all
the
companies who have tried this says it's
increased
employee productivity ross we've been
doing the five-day work week over here
for 100 years is it time to shave a day
off the week
i think we are just so trained in like
no we work monday through friday we've
been doing it forever
that it's sort of scary but when you
look at these stats you just
you can't deny that there's something
there i wonder now
if this is the best time to re-examine
it
because of the pandemic because of zoom
because we're all doing things in a more
technological way
this is the moment agreed and well a
three-day weekend would leave plenty of
time
for stuff like dating yeah and it
appears that in 2021 singles are ready
to mingle
people reports a new poll uh by plenty
of fish which is a dating app
survey with the cutest name ever daters
yeah they surveyed daters and they found
more than half of them out there felt
confident that this is the year
they would find the one people are
optimistic the survey found
that people are feeling more romantic
and more open uh to the
idea that they might not have considered
other people
before i think it's just really this i
think people have been locked inside for
so long
that by the time we get out there our
standards are going to be a little lower
we're just going to be like um are you
physically here okay i think i love you
one of the other things that i think the
article mentions
is that people are starting to
reevaluate their exes again like we're
at that point
yeah where it's like you know he wasn't
that bad now that it's been like a year
since i've been touched
yeah exactly right
i do love the notion that people are
feeling more optimistic and romantic
if not desperate i'll say this
maybe this is the year to find a one if
not the one
yeah would you even do you even believe
in the one i mean that's like a heavy
thing
no
i i believe in
um not scaring yourself
into thinking that you might have
already had the one
or to put all the stock into one person
that they have to fulfill everything for
you
there will be loves there will be
chapters
and um each and every one of them might
uh you know add up to something amazing
and you said it could be like just a
chapter and it could be a really long
chapter if you've with someone for a
long time but
i love the idea of just removing that
pressure this is the one it's got to be
the one
um and and you know maybe you can have
multiple ones
you can have multiple ones and for those
people who lock it down and
are happy forever as long as they both
shall live
wonderful like there is no right or
wrong mm-hmm
agreed agreed agreed are you you're my
one roster am i i
am yeah i don't feel any pressure
move over wellington um well the
pandemic has also affected the way that
we see
fashion i mean it has been a year of
homey comfort uh hello elastic
i know and now instyle reports that the
latest
on trend color reflects that the color
you
must work into your wardrobe immediately
is
ready drum roll potato brown
okay well from couch potato to the
trend in fashion there's so many ways to
wear it
it's a neutral so you can pair it with
bright neons or a bold print
or if you want that full head to potato
look oh no you didn't yes i did you can
go
monochromatic with it and i've
definitely dabbled in some potato brown
on this show
check out our instagram because you can
actually break down all the looks
that the genius lee harris is the
stylist on this show
and you can buy everything all these
great suggestions and how to's and where
shop the look if you will um ross are
you gonna shop for some spud duds or
what
well okay i i try to coordinate with you
every single day right and so when i'm
backstage and the show starts i'm
watching and i say oh what you gonna
wear what you gonna wear
and when you wear potato that's when i
freak out because
i we know what i look like if i wear
potato
a potato that's what i look like right
no matter how you slice me or dice me i
look like a potato
and so like when you wear this for
example i get very very excited because
i've had this in my
i've been on my rack back there waiting
uh and look how cute we look
i think you are just minty fresh and
beautiful
thank you for noticing you can pull off
a potato i'm not so much i look like a
walking tater tot
well oh god i love tater tots that just
made me want one
let me tell you something a tater tot is
the most underrated potato product and
i've proudly said it for years
i love the potato tater tot